this is the Kin one and this is the kin
to the kin one is cute adorable because
it's so small for some reason you don't
expect very much of it other than what
it delivers it's a little window into
your social media universe shows all
your Twitter and Facebook updates here
and Windows Live if you're involved in
that and even news feeds that you pick
it's got a really basic browser and sort
of Kluge mail app but it works and it
only cost 50 bucks the catch is you have
to sign up for a forty dollar a month
voice plan and a thirty dollar month
data plan and a two year contract from
verizon which means over the long term
you're looking at over thirty four
hundred dollars for this cute little guy
the kintu has a bigger keyboard
obviously so it's a little easier to
type on and it's got an eight megapixel
camera instead of the 5 megapixel camera
on the Kin one and honestly whereas the
Kin one takes terrible pictures this one
takes slightly better pictures I
wouldn't exactly recommend the kin too
because with a phone like this it's
basically inviting comparison to much
smarter phone like the motorola droid
the backflip all of which are much
smarter android based phones that have
full-sized keyboards like this but also
can do things like run apps they've got
much better web browsing capabilities
much better email and in particular
gmail integration and a lot of other
things so the Kin platforms shortcomings
become really apparent on this phone
whereas on the Kin one it's just so cute
that pretty much what you see is what
you get and you don't expect any more
from it other than keeping you in touch
with your friends would I recommend
either of these phones not really there
are other much better phones out there
that aren't going to saddle you with a
seventy dollar a month verizon contract
for two years but if you're a rich
parent and you've got a tween in your
house I'd say the kin one might be a
nice present because it's a great way
for them to keep in touch with their
friends on Facebook and who knows maybe
they'll send you an email once in a
great while